just saying the acronym NASA conjures
images of chiseled Jaw astronauts posing
beneath shining rocket ships assorted
super Geniuses huddling around computer
screens and a random woman giving a
dolphin a hand job wait what over the
years this stored organization has had
the odd mishap like the time the 300
million Mars climate Orbiter was lost
because one of its software systems used
met units and another Imperial it hit
Mars's atmosphere and immediately
exploded but there's been no blunder
more bunkers than the batshit crazy
dolphin project that NASA funded in the
1960s this might just be the most absurd
experiment in the history of modern
science involving interspecies sex drugs
and a woman living in a flatshare with a
dolphin called Peter